MICHALE FEE: Today
we're going to continue
building our equivalent
circuit model of a neuron.
Again, this is the
Hodgkin-Huxley model,
and the model was
really developed
around explaining how neurons
generate action potentials.
There are two key
ion channels that are
associated with making spikes.
There's a sodium
channel that we model
as a conductance in
series with a battery,
and there's a
potassium conductance
that we model the same way.
And again, those
two conductances
cooperate to produce
an action potential.
And we saw, essentially,
how those two conductances,
together with their
batteries-- the sodium battery
is up at plus 50
or so millivolts.
The potassium battery is down
at minus 75 or so millivolts.
And those two conductances then
work to essentially connect
the inside of the neuron
to the plus battery
and then to the minus battery
to give you an action potential.
And you may remember that
we saw what that looks like.
So here is plotting
membrane potential in blue.
Here, we turn on this
sodium conductance.
The voltage of the cell
races up to about plus 55.
Then we turn off the sodium.
We turn on the potassium.
The voltage goes down
to minus 75 or so.
And then we turn off
both conductances,
and the cell recovers.
So you can see that that
basically produces what
looks like an action potential.
That's the basis of action
potential production.
But in order to understand how
these things turn on and off
in the time course
that they do, we
need to understand
a little bit more
about how these sodium and
potassium conductances work.
And that's what we're
going to focus on today.
So let's just start
building our model.
So each one of those
conductances with a battery
is associated with a current.
There's a current
that goes through each
of those conductances.
The total current
through the membrane,
the ionic current through the
membrane in the Hodgkin-Huxley
model is a sum of three
components, actually--
a sodium current, a
potassium current--
those two we just talked about--
and a leak current that
is just a fixed current.
So the sodium and
potassium currents
are functions of
time and voltage.
The leak current, the leak
conductance, is just fixed.
And it has a battery of
about minus 50 millivolts.
And it just tends to keep the
cell sort of hyperpolarized.
And these two currents,
these two conductances,
do the job of making
an action potential.
So the total membrane
current is just
a sum of those three parts.
And now we can just take
that membrane current
and plug it into this equation
for the voltage as a function
of current now and solve
that differential equation
to get the voltage to calculate
how the voltage evolves
in time in the presence of
these membrane currents.
All right, so you recall
from the last lecture
that you watched on video
that these currents can be
written down as a conductance.
So let's just start here.
This is the most
similar one to the one
that you saw in the
previous lecture.
The current is
just a conductance
times a driving potential.
And we described
how that equation
can be summarized in
electrical circuit components
as a resistor, which is
one over the conductance,
times a driving potential,
which is basically
just the voltage drop
across the conductance.
Now, each of these conductances,
each of these currents,
is going to be written down
by a very similar equation.
So the potassium current is
just the potassium conductance
times the driving
potential for potassium,
which is just the membrane
potential minus the Ek.
And the sodium current is
just the sodium conductance
times the driving
potential for sodium,
which is the membrane potential
minus the sodium battery.
Any questions?
Yes?
AUDIENCE: How did
the [INAUDIBLE]..
MICHALE FEE: Yeah.
So unless I've made a mistake,
I've tried to put these--
remember that the
potassium battery is minus,
is negative, right?
And the sodium
battery is positive.
So I've tried to
show that by putting
the batteries in the
opposite direction, right?
So the battery
symbol has one side
that's supposed to
indicate positive voltage,
and the other side is negative.
So because they have
the opposite sign,
I've put them in backwards,
in the opposite direction.
Does that make sense?
Don't worry about that too much.
If I ask you to draw
this, I don't really
care that much which
way these things go.
I just want you to
know that this one is
negative on the inside
and that the sodium is
positive on the inside.
This is the inside of
the cell here, right?
The sodium battery
drives the inside
of the cell toward
positive voltage,
because you have positive
ions flowing into the cell.
So you can see now that
the membrane potential here
depends on the membrane currents
through this differential
equation.
But the membrane currents--
the sodium, potassium, and leak
currents-- all depend on
these conductances, right?
And these conductances for
the sodium and potassium
are voltage dependent
and time dependent.
So you can see that
the conductances
depend on the voltage, right?
So the membrane potential
depends on current.
Current depends on conductances,
but the conductances
depend on the
membrane potential.
So it goes around and
around and around, right?
So those things all
depend on each other.
And so what we are
setting out to do
is to write down the way those
things depend on each other,
the way you can think about
that system evolving in time.
So let me just show
you what the plan is.
So the plan is to write down
an algorithm-- basically,
a for loop--
that describes how the neuron
generates an action potential.
Let me just walk you
through the steps of that,
and then I'll get
to your question.
So we're going to start with
some membrane potential V,
and we're going
to calculate that
the voltage-dependent parameters
of the sodium and potassium
conductance using that
membrane potential.
And once we have
those parameters,
we can actually calculate the
conductance for each of those,
for the sodium and potassium.
Once you know the conductance,
you can get the currents.
Once you have the
currents, you can
compute the total
membrane current, just
by adding them all together.
Then, you can compute--
once you have all
those currents,
you just compute V infinity,
which is just the current times
the resistance, the
effective resistance.
Then we're going to
integrate our first order
linear differential equation to
get a new voltage as a function
of time and V infinity.
And we're just going to
go back and start again.
The so that's the
algorithm that a neuron
uses to generate a spike.
And that's what we're
going to work out.
Now, we've talked
about these things
over the last few
lectures, how you
can relate total
current to V infinity
and then integrate a first
order linear differential
equation, which is just
relaxing exponentially
toward V infinity.
But now we're going to put
these things in, figure out
the voltage and time
dependence of the sodium
and potassium conductances.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
MICHALE FEE: Yes.
It's primarily potassium.
It has a negative potential.
But it's just constant,
so we're not really
going to pay much
attention to it.
So if the sodium and
potassium currents are off,
then the leak current still
keeps the cell hyperpolarized.
All right, any questions?
That's the big picture.
So here are our
learning objectives.
I'd like you to be able to
draw that circuit diagram,
not worrying about the long
and short sides of the battery.
We're going to talk
about how we measure
the properties of ion channels.
That's called a voltage clamp.
So I want you to be able
to describe what that is.
I'd like you to be able to
plot the voltage and time
dependence of the potassium
current for today.
The next lecture, we'll talk
about the sodium current,
so we'll add that to our list
of things that we need to know.
But for today, I'd
like you to able
to plot the voltage and time
dependence of the potassium
current and conductance.
And be able to
explain, biophysically,
where the time and voltage
dependence of that potassium
conductance comes from and
be able to write it down
in terms of quantities
that are called
the Hodgkin-Huxley
gating variables.
So that's the plan.
All right, so let's come
back to our circuit.
Again, we have a
sodium current that's
sodium conductance times the
sodium driving potential.
The conductance is voltage
and time dependent.
The equilibrium
potential for sodium,
again, is plus 55 millivolts.
The potassium current is
just potassium conductance
times the potassium
driving potential.
The driving potential
is reference
to a battery in equilibrium
potential at minus 75.
And the leak has a battery
at minus 50 millivolts.
So those are the parts
we're going to use.
We're going to describe now
the experiments that Hodgkin
and Huxley did to extract
the parameters of the sodium
and potassium conductances.
Today, we're going to focus
on the potassium conductances.
And then on next
Tuesday, I guess,
we're going to do the sodium.
All right, so the reason
Hodgkin and Huxley studied--
so they studied these
channels, the potassium
and sodium channels, in
the giant squid axon.
Now, most of our
axons are about a--
most of the axons in our brain
are about a micron across.
This axon is about
a millimeter across.
Action potentials propagate
much faster in large axons,
and this axon is involved
in transmitting an action
potential from the
brain to the tail that
drives an escape reflex.
The squid squirts water out
of sort of a chamber that
has water in it.
If the squid senses
danger, it contracts
muscles that squeeze water out
of that, and it makes a jet.
And it squirts the squid
forward away from danger.
So that action potential has
to propagate very quickly
from the brain to the
tail, and it does that
through this enormous axon.
That axon is so big you can
now put multiple wires inside
of it.
You don't even need to pull
these glass electrodes.
You can just take little
wires and stick them in--
chop out a little
piece of the axon
and stick wires inside
of it and study it.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: So if the
body of this squid
is like a giant [INAUDIBLE]
it has arms coming out
of its head?
MICHALE FEE: Yes.
You eat that part,
and you eat that part.
Not that.
You throw away the
most interesting part.
OK, any other questions?
All right, so now
we're setting out
to measure these sodium and
potassium conductances, OK?
So how do we do that?
So what we really
want to do is to set--
we want to measure
conductance, which
is the relation between
voltage and current.
So we'd like to do
is to be able to set
the voltage at a certain level
and measure the current that
flows through these channels.
So you really want to
plot the IV curve, right?
You want to set the voltage,
measure the current,
and do that at a bunch
of different voltages.
And you recall that the
conductance is basically
just the slope of that
curve, right, that line.
So the job is set
voltage, measure current,
extract conductance.
Now, the problem with
that is that as soon
as you set the
voltage of the axon
somewhere up here in
an interesting range,
the thing begins to spike.
And then the voltage is
no longer constant, right?
So it becomes really
hard to make measurements
like this if you depolarize
the cell a little bit
to set try to set the
voltage and all of a sudden,
it's [MIMICS BUZZING].
It's generating spikes.
So what do you do?
So the trick is to develop a
device called a voltage clamp.
This thing basically
holds the-- so,
look, if the action potential
were really, really slow,
then you could actually
set the voltage.
You could change the current
being injected into the cell
by hand.
You say, OK, I'm trying to
set the voltage at zero.
Oh, it got a little
bit too high,
so I turn the current down.
Now the voltage
has gone too low,
so now I turn the current up.
You could do it by hand
if the action potential
were super slow, if it took
a minute to generate, right?
But the action potential
takes a millisecond.
So that's just too
fast for you to follow.
So you just make a
little electrical circuit
that does that job for you.
It uses feedback to set
the voltage where you want.
So you put a--
here's your cell.
Here's your membrane
resistance or conductance
that you're trying to measure.
You put a electrode in the cell.
You put it into a
little amplifier called
an operational amplifier.
And then on the other
side of that amplifier,
that differential
amplifier, you put
the command voltage that
you're trying to set.
So here's the way it works.
Basically, this thing tries
to set the membrane potential.
It tries to make this
value, this voltage,
equal to that voltage.
And it does that by feeding
current back into the cell.
Does that make sense?
OK, so you use an
operational amplifier.
An op amp has two inputs--
a plus input, a minus input.
The output is just a gain
times the plus input minus--
the positive input minus
the negative input.
And the gain is really big.
It's about a million.
So if this input is a
little bit above that input,
this output is big and positive.
If this input is
less than that input,
you can see this is negative.
And so the output
is big and negative.
Any questions?
So don't get confused here.
That G is gain, not conductance,
just for the next few slides.
So how does this work?
You can see that if the
membrane potential is
less than the command
voltage, then the output
voltage is positive and big.
That drives current
into the cell, which
increases the membrane
potential and makes it
approach the command voltage.
If the membrane potential
is larger than the command
voltage, then this thing--
this is bigger than this.
So this is negative.
And that pulls current
out of the neuron
and decreases the
membrane potential.
And in both cases,
the membrane potential
is being pulled toward
the command voltage.
And you can show, if you
just plug in these variables
into a couple of
equations, that as long
as the gain is big enough,
the membrane potential
is forced to be very close
to the command voltage.
All right, so that's
the voltage clamp.
It drives whatever current
is necessary to clamp
the voltage of the cell
at the command voltage.
And then what we do is
during an experiment,
we step the command
voltage around.
The cell tries to spike.
Those currents turn on.
The cell tries to
spike, but this thing
keeps the voltage locked
at whatever it is that you
want the voltage to be.
And then you measure the
amount of current required.
You just measure the
amount of current flowing
through this
resistor here that's
required to hold the
cell at any voltage.
All right, any questions?
Voltage clamp-- very cool.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: Can you
explain gain again?
MICHALE FEE: Gain is
just the multiplier
here in this equation.
So if there's a tiny difference
between the two inputs,
the output is bigger.
That's what gain means, right?
If the gain is a million, if
there's a microvolt difference
between the two inputs, the
output will be about a volt.
And it would be a plus or minus,
depending on which of those two
was more positive.
OK, so now let's get to the
actual voltage clamp experiment
that Hodgkin and Huxley did.
Here, we have two
wires in our cell-- one
to measure voltage and the
other one to inject current.
That's exactly what they did.
There's one wire here.
That's a little piece of axon.
You can literally cut the
squid open, find that axon.
It's a big, white-looking tube
about a millimeter across.
Cut two pieces of it, take two
wires, stick one in each end.
I drew it like this, but
if you did it that way,
they'd probably short together.
So then one of those
measures the voltage.
You set a command,
and the other wire
allows you to inject
current inside the axon.
And then you seal the ends
with a little bit of Vaseline.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: Sorry, what
is the command VC?
MICHALE FEE: VC is
the command voltage
that you're trying to set
the inside of the cell to.
Remember, here,
we're setting the--
VC is what you're controlling
as the experimenter.
You're setting the
voltage with that command.
So the voltage clamp
then holds the inside
of the cell at that
command voltage,
and then you're measuring
the current with this device.
There's a readout that tells
you how much current it's
putting into the cell, or it
goes onto an oscilloscope,
because it's time dependent.
So let's do an experiment.
Here's an example
of an experiment.
They hold the
command at minus 65.
And suddenly, they drop the
command voltage to minus 130.
What does the cell do?
What is the current?
Nothing.
There's a little transient here,
which is the amount of current.
It took to charge that capacitor
up to minus 130 millivolts,
and then nothing happens.
All right, let's do
another experiment.
Now we're going to start
our cell at minus 65
and suddenly jump the
voltage up to zero.
So we're going to
depolarize our cell.
And now something happens.
We get a big pulse of
current that's negative.
What does negative mean?
Anybody remember
what negative current
means by our definition?
Negative means that there
are positive ions going
into this cell.
So it's charging the cell up.
This is membrane current now.
So you just have to
remember that definition.
Negative membrane current
means that positive charges
are going into the cell, and
that's depolarizing the cell.
And then that negative current
lasts for a few milliseconds,
and then the current reverses
sign and becomes positive
and stays on.
So what is that?
So the first thing that
Hodgkin and Huxley did was they
tried to figure out what causes
that pattern of currents.
So here's what they did.
They had this idea that part
of this might be due to sodium.
And so what they did was
they did an experiment
where they replaced
sodium outside the cell,
outside the axon, with an ion.
They kept the chloride, but
they replaced the sodium
with choline.
So they used choline chloride,
so it's a salt solution,
but it has no sodium in it.
And then they redid
that experiment.
And here's what they found.
What they found was-- so
here it is-- with sodium,
and if they replace
the sodium, they
find that they get
almost the same thing,
except that initial
negative pulse goes away.
And so they hypothesized that
that part is due to sodium.
And so now you just
subtract this from this
to get the difference.
And that is the sodium current.
Does that make sense?
And then one other thing.
Through another
set of experiments,
they were able to show
that this part that's
left after you block
or remove sodium
is actually due to potassium.
So this is the
potassium current.
That is a sodium current.
So by doing different
kinds of experiments--
so one of the things that you're
able to do that they didn't do
initially, but later, they
were able to do things
like take that
little piece of axon,
take out a little miniature
paint roller, squish the axon,
roll the roller over the axon,
squish its guts out, and then
fill it up again with solutions
that they control that have
different ions in them.
And so they're able to study--
just do multiple different
kinds of experiments
to be sure that this
slow thing that turns on,
this slow positive
current is potassium,
and this fast negative
current is sodium.
All right?
So now what you
can do is you can
do this experiment at
different voltages here, right?
We want to measure how
these currents depend
on voltage, right?
We can see here how
they depend on time.
We can also see how
they depend on voltage,
by doing this experiment
at different voltages.
You start at some
negative potential.
You step the voltage up to minus
40, or you step it up to zero,
or you step it up to 40.
And now you can measure
that potassium current
as a function of
time, or the sodium
current as a function of time.
All right?
At different voltages.
All right, so those look kind
of weird, especially that one.
That looks kind of
scary, like what
the heck is going on there?
But it turns out that
both of these things
are actually pretty simple.
Once we dig a little bit more
into how these currents are
produced, you're going to see
that there's a very simple way
to understand what's
happening there.
All right, any questions?
Bear with me.
So now what we want
to do is we want
to measure the voltage
dependence of these things
kind of separately from
the time dependence.
So what we're going
to do is we're
going to measure the peak
potassium current, kind
of this steady state
potassium current
as a function of voltage.
So here's our IV
curve that I promised
that we were going to plot.
Peak current as a
function of voltage.
You can see that it's
approximately linear
above minus 50 or so millivolts.
The sodium current
looks kind of weird.
We're going to plot
the peak sodium current
as a function of voltage.
And we see that the peak sodium
current has this weird shape.
It's sort of linear up
here at positive voltages,
and then it crashes down to
zero at negative voltages.
All right?
Still kind of weird and scary.
So let's see if
we can understand
where this comes from.
I just replotted them here.
So now, remember that we
use this voltage clamp
to measure current as
a [AUDIO OUT] voltage.
But what is it that we're
really trying to understand?
We're really trying to
understand the conductances,
those resistors, right?
We're under trying to understand
the voltage and time dependence
of those conductances.
So we're trying to
extract conductance
as a function of voltage.
And remember that [AUDIO OUT]
is just conductance
times a driving
potential for potassium.
Sodium current is just sodium
conductance times the sodium
driving potential.
So we you could imagine
extracting the conductance
as current divided by
the driving potential.
This is what we're
really trying to find.
Rather than doing this
division, because this one
over-- this thing goes
to zero at the places
where the voltage is equal
to the equilibrium potential.
So we don't want to do that.
We're going to solve
this problem graphically.
So here's the driving
potential, right, V minus Ek.
It goes to zero at Ek, right?
And we want to find
a conductance that
makes this look like this.
So if this is kind
of a straight line,
if the current as a
function of voltage
is kind of a straight line
and this is a straight line,
what does that tell us about
the conductance in this region
up here?
It's constant.
Excellent.
Now, if the driving potential
is very negative here
but the current is zero,
then what's the conductance?
Driving potential
is big and negative.
Current is zero.
What does that tell us
about the conductance?
It's zero.
OK, so not so hard, right?
We have [AUDIO OUT] zero
here and constant here.
So can anyone just show me
what that might look like?
Good.
It could be like a jump.
It could be kind of smooth.
And that's exactly
what it looks like.
So the conductance is zero
here, which it has to be,
because the current is zero,
even though the the potential
is negative.
And the conductance
here is constant,
because the driving
potential is constant here.
The driving potential is linear,
and the current is linear,
so this needs to be
constant, all right?
So the conductance
is very simple.
It turns off at
negative voltages
and turns on and then stays
on at higher voltages.
Let's do that for sodium.
This thing looks
crazy, weird, right?
But let's go through
the same operation.
Here's our driving
potential for sodium.
Remember, it's got a
reversal at plus 55.
But it's a straight line, right?
That's a battery and a resistor.
So there's our
driving potential.
Now, this is linear.
This is linear.
So what does the conductance
look like up here?
Good.
This is zero, but this
is big and negative, so
what does the conductance
look like down here?
Good .
Starting to look
pretty familiar, right?
Boom.
It's exactly the same.
Both of these conductances are
off at negative potentials,
and they turn on at positive
voltages and remain constant.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
MICHALE FEE: Great.
Great question.
Because the sodium
conductance turns on,
and then it shuts
off right away.
And the shutting off is
a different mechanism.
So we're trying to figure out
how to ignore that and just
understand the voltage
depends of how it turns on.
Does that make sense?
And we'll get into
that next Tuesday.
But I'm showing both of
these at the same time
because they look
similar at the level
of the voltage dependence.
In fact, the way they
turn on is very similar.
It's just that the sodium has
some other weird thing that
shuts it off after
a few milliseconds,
and we'll talk about
that next time.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
MICHALE FEE: No, it's not.
But any non-linearity
here, we're
going to account for by
changes by voltage dependence
of the conductance.
So great point.
It's a subtlety that
we have kind of imposed
by this way of writing
down the voltage dependents
of the current.
Any other questions?
No?
OK, pushing on.
So this kind of gradual
turning on, this sort of zero
conductance down here
and a [INAUDIBLE] up
here, that's called a
sigmoidal voltage dependence.
And it's the voltage
dependence of activation.
It's how these channels turn on.
And as I said
before, we're going
to deal with the other
properties of the sodium
channel that turn it off later.
So both have a sigmoidal voltage
dependence of activation.
And if you plot this,
you can see that--
if you plot this on
a log scale here--
log scale on conductance,
linear here on potential.
You can see that
both of these curves,
both the potassium
and the sodium,
have this very characteristic
exponential turn-on followed
by his saturation and constant
conductance at higher voltages.
All right, any questions?
That's voltage dependence.
Now we're going to turn
to time dependence.
So you can see that
the time dependence--
so this driving potential,
that's just constant.
That just depends on the voltage
and the reversal potential.
And so we can separate out--
this thing is just
any time dependence
this has is dependent on the
time dependence of the voltage.
But in our voltage
clamp experiments,
the voltage is constant.
So this thing is constant.
So any time
dependence [AUDIO OUT]
current has to be due to time
dependence of the conductance,
right?
And what that means
is we can just
look at the shape of this
potassium current-- remember,
this is the potassium
current here.
That time dependence is
just due to time dependence
of the conductance.
Does that make sense?
So what's happening is
the potassium conductance
is starting at zero.
The moment you step
the voltage up,
that thing begins to
grow gradually and then
runs up to a constant
potassium conductance in time.
It starts off, ramps
up, and then becomes
constant, all right?
So that's the time dependence.
Sort of gracefully turns on.
That process of turning
on is called activation.
The sodium conductance--
or current, the same thing.
The sodium current is just
the sodium conductance.
The sodium current is
a function [AUDIO OUT]
is the sodium conductance
as a function of time,
times a constant.
In our voltage clamp
experiment, again, this voltage
is constant.
So the sodium
conductance turns on.
That's activation.
But then it turns off, and
that's called inactivation.
So the sodium current
has [AUDIO OUT]
sodium conductance
has two things going
on-- one, activation, and
the second is inactivation.
And it turns out these are
two separate biophysical
mechanisms.
And we're going to spend
more time on this next week.
So, notice something
interesting.
The sodium conductance turns on.
You depolarize the cell.
Sodium conductance turns on
right away and then shuts off.
The potassium conductance has
a delay, and then it turns on.
Does that look familiar?
It looks an awful
lot like this, right?
Here's the sodium conductance.
Turns on and then shuts off.
And then the
potassium conductance
turns on with a delay.
And that gives us
an action potential.
So you can see that when
you use voltage clamp
and dissected out the time
difference of the sodium
and potassium
conductance, it looks just
like the thing we
concocted earlier, just
sort of our toy example for how
to make an action potential.
Pretty cool, right?
OK, it's starting to come
together piece by piece.
So we're now going to
dig in a little bit
deeper into the biophysics
of how you get these voltage
and time dependencies.
So we're going to
derive the equation
for the voltage dependence.
Anybody want to
take a crazy guess
on how we're going to do that?
Just a wild guess, how you might
derive the voltage dependence
of something?
No?
OK.
We're going to use the
Boltzmann equation.
And we're going to derive
different equations that
describe the way those
channels turn on,
how those conductances turn on.
All right?
And once we do that,
we're going to have
a simple set of equations--
and not just equations.
We're going to have
a set of processes
that we can think of
as happening a loop,
in a for loop.
That's our algorithm
for an action potential.
All right, so let's dive
into single channels
and see how they work.
So, of course, currents
result from ionic flow
through ion channels.
It's actually possible
to record currents
from single ion channels.
We can actually make a
version of our voltage clamp
that we can attach to
a single ion channel.
And the way you do that is--
so when you take this piece
of glass and you pull it,
instead of poking
it through the cell,
instead of making
it really sharp
and poking it through
the cell, what you do
is you make it a
little bit blunter,
so it's got kind of a rough end.
And then you can
fire a polish-- you
can hold the end of that
electrode into a flame.
Not quite.
It's usually a filament
that heats up hot.
You hold the end
of the electrode
near this hot filament
and it melts the tip
into a nice, round--
it's still a tube, but
the edges of the tube
are nice and smooth.
And now when you take that
tube and you press it up
against the cell--
actually, you attach
a little plastic tube
to the end of the glass, and
you press that that electrode up
against the cell.
And you actually literally
suck on it with your mouth
onto that tube.
And it sucks the membrane
up against that smooth end
of the electrode.
And it sticks.
The lipids of the membrane
actually seal themselves
onto the end of the glass.
So now no currents can flow
out through these edges
here, all right?
And then you hook it
up to a very sensitive
current amplifier.
And now you can
control the voltage.
You can actually just
rip that off of the cell,
so now there's no more cell.
You just have an ion
channel sitting there
on a piece [AUDIO OUT]
on the end of your glass.
Now you can do a
voltage clamp experiment
and study the current--
the voltage dependence
of the current
through that ion channel.
So here's what this looks like.
Here's one experiment.
We're going to
start at minus 100.
This is a potassium channel.
You depolarize the potassium
channel up to 50 millivolts,
and you see that that current,
through that single channel,
starts flickering on and off.
Here's another trial.
Turns on, turns off,
turns on, turns off.
You can do that
a bunch of times.
You can see something
interesting.
The current is either off--
doesn't turn on gradually,
doesn't change smoothly.
It just flickers
between on and off.
That's a very important
aspect of ion channels.
But if you average all
those trials together,
you see that you get an
average current that looks just
like the current
that Hodgkin-Huxley
measured in the whole axon.
How is that possible?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
MICHALE FEE: Yeah.
Good.
So, basically,
what we're doing is
we're measuring one
ion channel many times.
But on a cell, you're
measuring a bunch
of ion channels, each of which
is doing something like this.
But they're happening
all at the same time,
and the current
is being averaged.
So here, we're averaging
the current one at a time.
And on a whole cell, we're
just averaging a bunch of them
at once.
It's called
ergodicity in physics.
It's called the
ensemble average.
OK, you can do the
same thing for sodium.
You take your patch,
a new patch electrode.
Fire polish it.
Push it up to a cell.
Apply some suction.
Glues on.
This time, we had
a sodium channel.
And now you can see
that the thing, again,
flickers on, flickers off,
flickers on, flickers off.
But now, they all flicker
on right at the beginning,
and then they flicker
off and stay off.
And if you average all
those different trials,
you see an ensemble
average sodium current
that looks just like when
you measure the sodium
current on a whole axon, OK?
But the key thing is that these
channels have two states--
on and off-- and they
flicker back and forth
between those two states,
conducting and non-conducting.
So we can now write down--
we could start
working with this idea
that our ion channels are
either open or closed.
And we can think
of a probability
that the channel is being
open, that the channel is open.
And we can have a total
number of channels.
The number of open
channels is just
the number of channels you
have times the probability
that any one of them is open.
If g is the inductance
of one open channel,
then we can write down the
total potassium conductance
as the probability that any
given ion channel is open
times the number of channels
times the inductance of one
open channel.
Does that make sense?
And now the claim
here [AUDIO OUT]
all of the interesting
voltage and time dependence
of these channels happens here.
Obviously, the number of them
isn't changing very rapidly.
The conductance per channel
is constant, per open channel.
So the interesting stuff
is in the probability
that the channel [AUDIO OUT].
And if we want to
get the current,
we're just going to plug this
conductance into here, OK?
All right, so let's start
with a potassium channel.
Let's dig in a little bit
deeper into what the potassium
channel looks like.
Potassium channel is formed
by four identical subunits.
They're produced
separately by ribosomes.
They form a
heteromer, a tetramer.
And that tetramer
has a hole that
runs down the middle of it,
which is where the ions flow.
Each of these subunits
has a voltage sensor that
allows it to turn on and off.
In order for the channel to be
on, all four of those subunits
has to be open.
So each subunit has an open
state and a closed state.
And for the channel to
be open, all four of them
have to be in the open state.
So if n is the probability
that any one subunit is open--
I meant to make you guys
answer this question
before I showed the answer.
But is it clear how
if any one subunit has
a probability of
being open of n,
then the probability that
the whole channel is open
is n to the four?
This n is called
a gating variable.
I would like you to know that
the probability that a sodium
potassium channel is
open is n to the four.
That's an important thing
for you to remember.
That assumes that those four
subunits are independent.
And in potassium
channels, that's
a very good approximation.
So we can now write down the
conductance of our potassium
channel--
something times n
to the four, where
that something is that
inductance of one ion channel.
So we can now write
down the current as n.
Open conductance times n to the
four times a driving potential.
And that n is called
the gating variable
for the potassium conductance.
All right, any questions?
No?
Yes?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
MICHALE FEE: n absolutely
does depend on voltage.
Very good.
That's where we're going next.
But before we go on
to that, I wanted
to add one other thing,
which I think is really cool.
We're going to do the voltage
dependence of a potassium
channel using the
Boltzmann equation.
So here's the way you think
about a potassium channel
working.
Here's a potassium channel.
We're showing a cross-section.
Here it is.
Here's the membrane,
the lipid bilayer.
Here's our potassium channel,
sitting in the membrane.
And we're taking a cross-section
through that tetramer
that shows two subunits.
And I'm showing
the voltage sent--
I'm showing the mechanism
that that opens and closes
one of those subunits.
This subunit we'll also have a
voltage sensor and a gate that
looks the same.
So look, the voltage sensor--
how do you sense voltage?
You sense voltage
with charge, right?
Voltage differences, I should
say, you sense with a charge.
Because voltage gradients
are electric fields,
and electric fields
push on charges.
So if we want to detect
the voltage difference
across this membrane, we put
a charge in the membrane.
When the voltage
difference is zero,
there's little force
on those charges.
Now, if we suddenly
hyperpolarize the [AUDIO OUT]
cell so it's very
negative, now there's
an electric field
inside the membrane that
points toward the inside
of the cell, which
pushes those charges toward
the inside of the cell.
And now you can just have a
little mechanical linkage.
That's not really
what it looks like,
but there's some way that the
amino acids and the protein
are configured so that when
those charges get pushed on,
it closes a gate.
And now the current
can no longer
flow through the ion channel.
OK, so now we're going
to derive how this--
we're going to see how to
derive this voltage dependence
from the Boltzmann equation.
All right, so, everybody,
this is just for fun.
I don't expect you to
know how to do this.
I just want you to see
it, because I personally
get chills when I see this.
It's really cool.
But I'm not expecting you to
be able to reproduce it, OK?
So just watch.
So, again, the
Boltzmann equation
says that the
probability of being
in two states, open or
closed, depends on the energy
difference between them.
So we have an open state
and a closed state.
And when the voltage
inside the cell
is zero-- when the voltage
difference between the inside
and the outside of the
cell is zero, [AUDIO OUT]
know that the sodium
channel likes to be open.
So what that means is that the
open state has a lower energy
than the closed state, right?
Sodium channel likes to open
when the cell is depolarized.
That means the voltage
inside and outside
are close to each other, right?
Open state has a lower
energy than the closed state.
Let's call that energy
difference delta u.
And it's close to kt,
because when it's open,
the channel kind of flickers
back and forth between open
and closed.
Does that make sense?
Now let's put on--
let's hyperpolarize
the inside of our cell.
So now the voltage
inside is low.
There's a voltage
gradient, an electric field
that is trying to
push those charges in.
Now, you can see that
those charges here
are sitting at a lower voltage.
So in the closed
state, those charges
are down here at
a lower potential.
What does that mean for the
energy of the closed state
when the cell is hyperpolarized?
Its lower.
The energy of the
closed state is low
because those charges are
toward the inside of the cell,
and the voltage is low.
Now, what happens if the
cell is hyperpolarized,
but it happens to be
in the open state?
You can see those charges
are closer this way.
So you can see that the
energy of-- these charges
are still sitting in a voltage
that's lower than outside.
So that open state has
a slightly lower energy.
But you can see that
the closed state still
has a much lower energy
than the open state, OK?
And we can write down
that voltage difference
as a gating charge times
this voltage difference.
So now let's just take--
here is an open state.
It has an energy difference
of a little amount, w.
Open state is lower than
closed by an amount w.
When the voltage
inside the cell is low,
we've decreased the
energy of the closed state
by this amount-- gating charge
times membrane potential.
And now we have an energy
difference in the open state
and the closed, the
energy difference
between the open
state and closed state
as a function of voltage.
We have a simple equation that
describes the energy difference
between the open and
closed state as a function
of the membrane potential.
And now we can just plug that
into the Boltzmann equation
and derive the probability
of being open and closed.
So we just plug that
delta u into here,
w minus gating
charge times voltage.
Now let's calculate the
probability of being open.
This gives us the ratio
of open to closed.
How do we calculate the
probability of being open?
Well, n is the
probability of being open.
That's just probability
of being open divided
by open plus closed.
What's the probability
of being open
plus the probability
of being closed?
Well, if it's in one or the
other, then the sum of those
has to be one, OK?
And now divide both
top and bottom by p0.
The probability of being open
it's just 1 over 1 plus p
closed over p open, which
is just the inverse of this.
And that's equal to that.
All right, that may have gone
by a little bit too fast.
And I wasn't very
smooth on that.
But you can see the idea, right?
It's estimating how
the energy difference
between the open
and closed state
depends on the
voltage of the cell,
and it's just an
energy difference.
So it has to be a charge
times a voltage, yeah?
And that's right [AUDIO OUT]
charge times a voltage.
And now we're just doing
a little bit of algebra
to extract the
probability of open
from open divided by closed.
And now if we just plug that
into there, we get this.
All right?
So now let's see how that
compares to the actual answer.
Probability of open is just 1
over 1 plus this exponential.
Here's what that
data looked like.
Remember, that was the
data for the conductance
as a function of voltage.
Here's a fit to a functional
form that looks like that.
And here is the
prediction from Boltzmann.
You can see that it
almost exactly fits.
And you can actually
extract, biophysically,
what the gating charge is
inside this tiny, little protein
simply by fitting
this to the data.
Pretty cool, right?
Yes?
AUDIENCE: What is w?
MICHALE FEE: It's
the energy difference
between the open and closed
state when the voltage is zero.
So you kind of have
to fit that, too.
If the voltage is zero,
it's the energy difference
between the open and closed
state when the voltage is zero.
And then you subtract from
that the energy of the gating
charge as a function of
voltage inside the cell, OK?
Yes
AUDIENCE: So is that
the [INAUDIBLE]..
MICHALE FEE: Yes,
each has the sensor,
and they all have to be open
for the ion channel to be open.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: Do you not need to
put it to the power of four?
MICHALE FEE: No, because
this is the probability
that one subunit is open.
But that's a good point.
If you want to
compare that to the--
so you're right.
If you want to compare
that to the conductance
of the whole
channel, then it has
to be raised to
the power of four.
And that's been
accounted for here.
Good question.
Any other questions?
Boltzmann men equation
is pretty cool.
If you know the mass
of a nitrogen molecule
and the acceleration
due to gravity,
what can you calculate with
the Boltzmann equation?
Any idea?
The mass of a nitrogen
molecule and the acceleration
due to gravity.
AUDIENCE: Pressure of nitrogen?
The partial pressure
of nitrogen?
MICHALE FEE: Close.
You can calculate the
height of the atmosphere.
You can do all kinds
of really cool stuff
with the Boltzmann equation.
OK, there was another
question here.
No?
So you can extract,
actually, these quantities--
the gating charge and this
energy difference in the zero
voltage state.
And the fit is very good.
OK, so that's
voltage dependence.
I highlighted
these slides that I
don't expect you to be
able to reproduce in blue,
just to make it more
clear for your review
what you have to focus on.
OK, let's look at
the time dependence.
The time dependence
is pretty simple.
It's going to just involve a
linear first order differential
equation.
You guys are all super
experts on that now, right?
So we have an ion channel--
sorry, a subunit that's
either open or closed, right?
We have an open
state, closed state.
What we're going to do is--
so the way to think about
this is the ion channel,
the subunit, if the
cell is polarized,
is sitting in the
closed state, right?
When you depolarize the neuron,
that changes the energy levels.
[AUDIO OUT] Which way was it?
I forget.
The closed state
has a lower energy.
Now, when you
depolarize the cell,
the closed state suddenly
has a much higher energy,
and it's close to
the open state.
And so, at some
point, that subunit
will jump over to the
open state, right?
But that takes time.
You change the energy
levels, but it takes time
for the system to jump
into the open state.
Why is that?
Because that transition is
caused by thermal fluctuations.
And so you have to wait for
one of those fluctuations
to kick you over
into the open state.
So we're going to
model those transitions
between open and closed states
with a simple rate equation
that's voltage dependent.
We have an open
state, and we imagine
that n is the probability
of being in the open state.
And we can equivalently
think of it
as if we have a
population of subunits.
And let's think of it
more as the fraction.
It's also equivalent to--
just whichever way you
want to think about it,
either works well.
But you can also think
of it as the probability
of being in the open
state, or the number
of subunits that are in the
open state in a population.
You also have a closed state.
So if n is the
probability of being
in the open state,
[AUDIO OUT] of a closed state
with probability
1 minus n, right?
If you're in the
closed state, you
have some transition rate,
probability per unit time,
of going from the closed
state to the open state.
And if you're in
the open state, you
have some probability
per unit time beta
of going into the closed state.
So those things have
units of per second,
probability per second.
Yes?
Rebecca, right?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
What's the cause for
the fluctuations?
Just regular [INAUDIBLE]?
MICHALE FEE: Just warmth.
And these things are
voltage dependent, remember?
Those depend on the
energy difference
between that open
and closed state.
All right, let's develop our
first order linear equation.
It's going be very simple.
We have a closed
state, an open state.
The change in the
number of open states
is just going to be the number
of closed states, the number
of closed subunits that
open, minus the number
of open subunits that close.
That makes sense?
All right, that's simple enough.
The change in the number
open subunits per unit time
is going to be the
number of closed subunits
that there are times
the probability
that a closed subunit
opens per unit time--
that's alpha-- minus--
remember, the number
of closed subunits
that open is the number
times the probability
per unit time
that a closed subunit
opens, all right?
And the number of open
subunits that close
is just the number of open
subunits times the probability
that any one of them
closes per unit time.
Does that make sense?
A lot of words, but the equation
ends up being very simple.
The change per unit
time of n is just
the number of close
subunits, one [AUDIO OUT],,
times the probability that
those open per unit time
alpha minus beta times n.
Alpha times 1 minus
n minus beta times n.
Any questions about that?
Alpha, beta are
voltage dependent.
So I've rewritten that equation.
n is the probability
that a subunit is open.
Let's just rewrite this.
Let's expand this.
Alpha minus alpha times
n minus beta times n.
Factor out the n.
So you have dn dt equals alpha
minus alpha plus beta times n.
Divide both sides by 1
over alpha plus beta.
What's the steady state
of this-- the steady state
solution of this equation?
That is the steady
state solution, right?
If you set dn dt equal to
zero, then n is equal to that.
[AUDIO OUT] just n infinity.
And what's that?
Alpha and beta have
units of per unit time.
So what is one-- what units do
1 over alpha plus beta have?
Time.
So what might that be?
AUDIENCE: Tau.
MICHALE FEE: Tau.
It's a time constant.
So, after all of this,
what we end up with
is an equation that looks
exactly like what we had for--
we have a first order linear
differential equation exactly
the same form as
the equation we used
to understand the way
the voltage changes
in a cell in response
to current injection.
So if we change n infinity,
what is this thing going to do?
What is n going to do?
It's going to relax [AUDIO OUT]
n infinity with a time
constant tau.
In all of these
things, the tau is
tau sub n, because it's
for the n gating variable.
So that's why this
has an n here.
So n infinity and tau
are voltage dependent,
because they come from
alpha and beta, which
are voltage dependent.
But we actually just derived the
steady state voltage dependence
of the potassium
conductance, right,
from the Boltzmann equation?
What is n infinity for
very negative voltages?
Do you remember it,
just approximately?
Big, small, [AUDIO OUT]?
What is the steady state?
What's the probability that
a potassium channel is open,
that a subunit is open,
at very negative voltages?
Do you remember?
Zero.
It's off.
For big voltage, n
infinity has to be--
if we think of it as a
probability, it's close to one.
So n infinity goes from
zero at negative voltages,
sigmoidal activation up
to one at high voltages.
OK, so now let's look at how n
changes as a function of time.
So here's our
[AUDIO OUT] potential.
We're going do a voltage
clamp experiment.
We're going to start at minus 80
millivolts and step up to zero.
So what is n
infinity going to do?
n infinity is just a
function of voltage, right?
It's like those energy levels.
They change immediately.
So what is n
infinity going to do?
Good.
It's going to start at close
to zero, jump up to one,
and then jump back to
close to zero immediately
following the voltage.
But what is n going to do?
Now let's plot n.
n is going to start at zero.
When you step the voltage
up, n infinity will jump up,
and n will relax exponentially
to a high n infinity
close to one, right?
And then when we
turn back, n infinity
jumps back down to zero, and
n relaxes exponentially back.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: On the n
[INAUDIBLE],, that's not
relaxing [INAUDIBLE] to one.
It's to n infinity,
right, at the top?
MICHALE FEE: Yes, but for
a voltage around zero,
n infinity is going
to be close to one .
Any questions?
That is called activation.
That's the activation.
Now, this looks a
little funny, right?
This thing is turning
on immediately.
It doesn't have that
nice sigmoidal shape
that the potassium current had,
or the potassium conductance.
Why is that?
What are we looking at here?
We're plotting n.
What is the potassium
conductance or the current?
How does that relate to n?
n to the fourth.
So what do we do to plot
the potassium current
or the potassium conductance?
We just take this
[AUDIO OUT],, right?
So what does that look like?
This process of turning off--
the gating variable getting
bigger is called activation.
The gating variable getting
smaller, n getting smaller,
is called disactivation.
So now let's plot
this to the fourth.
So this conductance
turns on gradually,
but the conductance
is proportional to n
to the fourth.
So let's plot that.
So if we plot n
to the fourth, you
can see that that function
now turns on smoothly in time.
This is time now, right?
So that gating variable
n relaxes exponentially,
but the conductance goes as the
gating variable to the fourth.
And so it has this nice,
graceful turn-on, right?
Because it's the
gating [AUDIO OUT]
exponential to the fourth
looks exactly like this.
In fact, that's how Hodgkin
and Huxley figured out
that it's n to the four, because
they knew that if they assume
that it's an exponentially
decaying gating
variable, that the only way
they could fit the turn on
of the conductance was by
raising it to the fourth power.
If they raised it to the second
power, it was still too sudden.
If they raised it
to the third power,
it was still not quite right.
But if they raised it to
the fifth power, oops,
it's too delayed.
If they raised it
to the fourth power,
it exactly fits the shape of
the conductance turning on.
And so they inferred--
they didn't know about subunits.
They just had a piece of
axon, a piece of squid lying
on a table in front of them.
And they were able to
figure out that there
were four independent processes
that turn on the potassium
conductance.
Pretty cool, right?
That's what you get by
doing things quantitatively.
So they could
[AUDIO OUT] the shape
of that potassium
conductance turning
on by this exponential
gating variable raised
to the fourth power.
And from that, they
were able to infer
that it's four independent first
order processes that combine
to produce that activation.
OK, the offset also fits if you
raise it to the fourth power.
They were able to measure
the size of the potassium
conductance to measure
n infinity directly.
So we derived it using
the Boltzmann equation,
but they measured
it directly just
by the size of the conductance.
And you can also
measure the time course.
You don't need to
worry about this.
I'm not expecting--
you should know this.
I'm just showing you
that just for fun.
You don't need to know that.
And you can extract
these tau's just
by measuring this exponential
decay at different voltages,
or measuring the inferred
first order process.
You can infer the time constant
of the first order process
on the onset and the offset
to extract these tau's
as a function of voltage.
This is tau as a
function of voltage.
From these two quantities,
you can actually
extract alpha and beta.
And so you can write down a
simple algebraic expression
for alpha and beta.
And that's the way they actually
wrote those things down.
They wrote them down as
alpha and beta, rather than n
infinity and tau.
Those are simple expressions
for alpha and beta
in units of per millisecond
as a function of voltage
in units of millivolts.
I think-- yeah, it's millivolts.
There it is right there.
So you can actually just
take those parameters
and calculate n
infinity and tau n
and calculate the gating
variable from that using
that differential equation.
So we have these
nice expressions
for what the steady state,
n infinity, and tau n are.
Now, why did we-- yes?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]?
MICHALE FEE: Yes,
they're per unit time.
Yeah, so they have units
of per millisecond.
OK, so now let's come
back to our picture.
We have n infinity and tau
n as a function of voltage.
Now we just can plug those
into this differential equation
and solve for n.
Well, we already
know what that does.
n relaxes exponentially
toward n infinity
with a time constant tau.
But you can integrate
that numerically.
You get the potassium
conductance as n to the four,
g times n to the four.
You get the potassium
current as g n to the four
times the driving
potential, or V minus Ek.
And now let's come
back to our algorithm
for making an action potential.
So we have the parts related
to the potassium current.
We still have to add the
parts related to sodium,
but it's going to
look very similar.
So here's the idea.
We start with the membrane
potential at time step t.
We compute n infinity and tau n.
We integrate dn dt one time
step to get the next n.
Plug n into our equation to
get the potassium current.
We then add that to
all the other currents
to get the total
membrane current.
We compute V
infinity of the cell.
We integrate dv dt one time
step to get the next voltage.
And you plug that in and
calculate the next n infinity,
all right?
So we still have to
add the sodium parts,
but you can see we've
gone through all
of these steps
for the potassium.
And so we're just
this shy of having
a full-blown algorithm
for [AUDIO OUT] an action
potential in a neuron.
And not only do you understand
all the little steps,
but you understand the
fundamental biophysics
that leads to that voltage
and time dependence.
All right, so, again, what
I'd like you to be able to do
is to draw that circuit,
the Hodgkin-Huxley model.
I'd like you to be able to
explain, at a basic level,
what a voltage clamp
is and how it works.
I'd like you to be able to plot
the voltage and time dependence
of the potassium current--
remember, this
sigmoidal activation
of the potassium current--
and the conductance, voltage
and time dependence.
And be able to explain the
time and voltage dependence
of the potassium
conductance in terms
of the Hodgkin-Huxley
gating variables.
OK?